[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo esseri artificiali
proprio così
il nostro modo di camminare di mangiare
di comunicare ma anche di sognare e
amare e artificiale dobbiamo ammetterlo
la nostra esistenza è solo lontanamente
biologica quasi tutto in noi e
tecnologia
anche se diciamo o pensiamo il contrario
da sempre al naturale preferiamo
l'artificiale al biologico il
tecnologico proprio in questi giorni
preferiremmo sentirci dire il contrario
preferiremmo sentirci dire
l'uomo se inter richiamo della natura
invece sono qui a dirvi il contrario
l'uomo sente il richiamo della
tecnologia dell'artificiale sono certo
perché sono in tanti a ripeterlo che
avrete sentito dire
la tecnologia disumanizza i social
network si imbruttiscono le intelligenze
artificiali che stanno arrivando c
spazzeranno via dalla storia del nostro
pianeta è proprio il contrario invece la
tecnologia da sempre umanizza la
tecnologia ci umanizza la tecnologia è
il driver della nostra umanità ma
mettiamoci d'accordo su cosa intendo per
tecnologia perché se chiedessi alla
platea che cos'è la tecnologia la
maggior parte di voi anzi forse la
totalità direbbe beh la tecnologia sono
i personal computer degli smartphone
giusto vero
questa però è l'ultima tecnologia per me
è la tecnologia è molto di più
sono tutti quegli oggetti artificiali
cioè di provenienza non naturale che ci
circondano
guardatevi intorno lo spazzolino per
lavarsi i denti la bicicletta la penna
con cui prendo appunti gli occhiali
questo palcoscenico il microfono che mi
permette di arrivare anche all'ultima
affida di questa meravigliosa platea a
pensarla come me ci sono altri per
fortuna
kevin kelly il fondatore di wired
america dice che la tecnologia è una
sorta di organismo vivente in continua
evoluzione e richard dawkins che ha
scritto uno dei più bei libri di
divulgazione scientifica il gene egoista
dice che questa evoluzione
avviene così velocemente da lasciare
indietro senza fiato la biologia la
nostra biologia
insomma noi siamo caratterizzati e
saremo sempre più caratterizzati dalla
tecnologia a queste considerazioni sono
arrivato dopo vent'anni di lavoro dopo
la laurea in fisica mi sono messo in
gioco e ho cominciato a lavorare
all'interno di un museo il museo
nazionale della scienza e della
tecnologia
ero immerso dalla tecnologia
il mio lavoro era misurare osservare e
descrivere catalogare e poi esporre al
pubblico oggetti tecnologici per un
lavoro scientifico con un certo punto
qualcosa è successo in ho cambiato
approccio si va bene mi interessava cosa
fosse con la tecnologia come funzionava
quali erano i materiali che misura aveva
ma mi interessava di più capire qual'era
l'impatto che quella tecnologia aveva
avuto nella cultura che lo aveva
assorbito uno sguardo antropologico
sociologico nel 2010 mi sono licenziato
io ho aperto un laboratorio di
fabbricazione digitale dove ancora oggi
lavoro in mezzo alla stampante 3d
macchine a controllo numerico e robot ma
il mio approccio è sempre lo stesso non
sono un tecnico mi interessa capire come
quelle tecnologie agiscono sul sociale
agiscono sul nostro main set
guardate in questi 20 anni ho imparato
tantissime cose come giusto che sia ma
posso riassumere in questo schema è uno
schema due tempi
il primo tempo va dall uomo alla
tecnologia ed è banale anche se
bellissimo
qui si nasconde la nostra creatività
l'uomo progetta tecnologie la nostra
inventiva la nostra innovazione la
nostra fame di nuovo ma la parte più
interessante di questo schema
il secondo passaggio è la detrazione che
a prestazione sull'uomo
la tecnologia progetta all'uomo proprio
così
una volta che queste tecnologie si
diffondono nella società della nostra
cultura
succede qualcosa di importante qui
dentro della nostra umanità
guardate applicare questo schema oggi è
davvero complesso le tecnologie sono
molteplici sofisticate e anche complesse
allora vi faccio fare un esercizio
torniamo indietro a 200.000 anni fa
all'inizio del nostro rapporto con la
tecnologia esisteva quello che noi
chiamiamo homo sapiens cioè l'uomo
secondo me non era ancora proprio homo
sapiens era ma sicuramente la sua
biologia e poi esisteva la natura gli
altri animali la vegetazione e magari
dei sassi sicuramente nei sassi
tra questi sassi uno in particolare
speciale si chiama selce è un oggetto è
un ente naturale ma è speciale davvero
perché se scalfito produce lame e punte
l'uomo sapiens casualmente è volutamente
non mi interessa ha trasformato questo
oggetto naturale in un oggetto
artificiale
la prima forma di tecnologia
l'utensile primordiale l'uomo progetta
tecnologia e come vi dicevo è più
interessante quello che succede dopo
questo oggetto questo utensile una volta
tra le mani dell'uomo ha cambiato la
nostra visione del mondo per sempre
pensate agli animali feroci come li
guardiamo prima e dopo questo oggetto
pensate ai legni che si trovava per
strada come posso lavorarli con una lama
e una punta allora capite che questo
processo va avanti da allora 200.000
anni sembrano tantissimi ma
biologicamente un soffio 200.000 anni
sono 8mila generazioni quattromila anni
fa
questa evoluzione giorno dopo giorno
mese dopo mese anno dopo anno ci ha
portato oggi alle intelligenze
artificiali alla robotica e ha portato
delle conseguenze fondamentali
alcune le abbiamo sotto gli occhi di
tutti i giorni facciamo finta di nulla
facciamo finta di non accorgersene la
prima è che pur avendo noi esseri umani
homo sapiens quasi il 99 per cento del
dna identico allo scimpanzé comune la
nostra aspettativa di vita è raddoppiata
loro muoiono a 40 anni mediamente noi a
80 anni
secondo voi c'entra la tecnologia certo
è lì il segreto della nostra longevità
non nella biologia che identica a quella
delle scimmie e come ci curiamo e come
ci vestiamo e come comunichiamo tra di
noi le idee che fa la differenza è
l'anti ufficiale che ci ha regalato una
seconda vita 40 anni in più di vita ma
guardate questo è un aspetto
fondamentale ma non sufficiente per
spiegare questa mio amore per la
tecnologia perché all'inizio della
nostra storia 200.000 anni fa con solo
la nostra biologia
noi eravamo destinati alla posizione
mediana della catena alimentare 200.000
anni dopo grazie al nostro uso della
tecnologia
siamo passati all'apice siamo là in cima
e queste delle conseguenze pratiche
siamo sempre nella nostra zona di
confort
nessun animale più ci spaventa
governiamo questo pianeta
e guardate anche questo mi interessa
poco naturalmente fondamentale ma quello
che mi interessa è che questa differenza
di potenziale tra dove dovremmo essere
e dove siamo dove dovremmo essere
biologicamente e dove siamo
tecnologicamente ha creato una cosa
strana in noi speciale le nostre paure
la nostra fragilità quel senso di essere
inadeguati ma anche tutti gli anticorpi
a questi sentimenti l'arte la
spiritualità la filosofia la musica la
matematica la scienza la nostra continua
voglia di esplorare di capire
l'innovazione in una sola parola la
nostra umanità
capita allora che dire che la tecnologia
disumanizza è una stupidata
in tutti i sensi la tecnologia ci rende
più umani allora io sono sicuro che tra
di voi ci sono ingegneri architetti
designer stampiamo c questa frase l'uomo
e tecnologia
e smettiamola di pensare che siamo solo
tecnici la nostra azione agisce sulla
progettazione dei nuovi umani dobbiamo
averne consapevolezza dobbiamo disegnare
e progettare la nuova umanità
attraverso questi strumenti è poi parlò
agli altri che sono tantissimi forse la
maggioranza quelli che usano la
tecnologia anche voi avete delle
responsabilità
parlate di tecnologia discutetene con
progettate la perché è lì che si
nasconde la nostra più profonda umanità
vi voglio lasciare con un messaggio che
possiate apprezzare da questa sera o da
domani mattina
amate la tecnologia e amerete la parte
più profonda e intima della vostra
umanità
grazie
[Applauso]